[MUSIC PLAYING]
TIM KELTON: We're
going to be talking
about building multi-tenancy
machine learning applications
with GKE and then using
Istio to gain visibility
into those applications.
And our goal as a
company is to really
better understand the Earth.
So that's what we're going to
be talking about for the next 40
minutes.
My name's Tim
Kelton, and I'm one
of the co-founders of a
startup called Descartes Labs.
And we're going to be showing
some of the machine learning
models that Descartes Labs
has built for its customers.
And just a warning,
I guess, we're
a very kind of pixel and
imagery-focused company.
So you're going to see lots
of satellite images and lots
of aerial imagery.
So I hope that's OK, and that
it will keep things exciting.
And then, we're going to
talk about how we leverage
Google Cloud and the
components we use,
specifically Google
Kubernetes Engine.
And then, we gain
a lot of visibility
by using Istio on top
of our microservices.
And then finally for an
exciting finale, my colleague
and our head of engineering,
Sam Skillman, will join me.
And we'll show a brief example
of running multi-tenancy
workloads--
machine learning
workloads on there.
So I hope you come away with
some great ideas about running
multi-tenancy and how Istio
can help give you visibility
into your microservices.
But I also really
hope you come away
with some ideas of how better
understanding changes that
are happening on our
Earth every single day
might actually impact
your businesses
or your organizations.
And gaining insight
into that can really
provide those insights.
So who here has heard
of Descartes Labs?
A few hands.
OK, that's actually
kind of awesome.
Our story is a little different
than the stereotypical Silicon
Valley startup.
While we do have Silicon
Valley VC funding
and we do have veteran
Silicon Valley leadership,
we're actually quite--
and we have offices
here and in New York--
our headquarters
are actually way up
in the mountains of
Santa Fe, New Mexico.
And it's kind of a weird place
for a startup in one way,
but that's because myself and
the rest of the founding team
were scientists, researchers,
and engineers at Los Alamos
National Laboratory.
And there, we were
actually working on machine
learning and applying that to
a range of real world problems,
including remotely
sensing the Earth.
And so the Cloud, we
don't have a data center.
We don't even own
a single server.
So the Cloud, we
basically couldn't exist
without this infrastructure.
Yet, on any given day, our staff
of scientists can build models,
and they can build them
over petabytes and petabytes
of data.
And they can scale them
on thousands of cores.
And that's all basically
because of the Cloud,
and that that's
really why we're here.
So our story is a bit of--
in some ways, it's
really about sensors.
And in some ways we're
looking at sensing the Earth.
But sensors are really at an
inflection point right now.
They're changing
from a world where
data was kind of individually
collected or manually
entered to one
where it's basically
being continuously sourced and
automatically input by sensors.
They're getting better
and better resolution.
We're seeing better range,
better data transmissions
of sensors, and the costs are
just dramatically decreasing.
This is everything from things
I use riding my mountain
bike but all the way
up into the satellites
and remotely sensing the Earth.
Just not that long ago,
almost all satellites
were basically
government funded.
So they cost
hundreds of millions
of dollars for a project.
And now, an engineering lab
student can make a CubeSat
and can launch
that up into space.
Or they can mount a sensor that
they've made in a laboratory
to measure things
like radio frequency.
They can mount that to a drone
or fly it around on a plane.
So this world is changing,
and it's basically
becoming a continuous--
we've gone from these infrequent
samples to almost continuous--
excuse me-- continuous
measurements.
And one of the really
big core challenges
that we've always
had with satellites
and remote sensing of data is
getting access to the data.
Sure, you could click
and download an image,
and it was made for
that human interaction
and that human analyst.
But with machine learning,
that really has changed.
We can process and
look at imagery
that humans will never, ever
look at in our lifetimes
again, because there's
just so much data.
And the Cloud has been
one of the big enablers
in the last few years.
It's now finally
possible to process
and have every single
piece of satellite imagery
or aerial imagery or
remotely sensing data
and have that available and
basically build that and make
it machine learning-ready.
And so this imagery that
we put into our platform
is fully global in coverage.
And then, it crosses many
different spectrums of light.
Behind me, that's showing
near-IR on a global composite.
And then, it's across
many different modalities.
Sure, we have human
visible light,
but this is something called
synthetic aperture radar.
It's not where the sun
shines off the Earth,
bounces off the Earth,
and a camera captures.
Instead, the satellite emits
a radar signal actually
down onto the Earth, bounces
that off, and captures it.
It's giving us a global
height measurement
around the whole world.
And then, it's through time.
And often, it's this
temporal cadence
that provides maybe the
greatest analytical insight
when we're building models.
Behind me is NASA's
MODIS imagery.
This is showing
vegetative health.
That's that really,
really bright green.
And this is showing a
single frame for every day.
So this is looking down
everywhere in the US every day,
and this is 15 years of imagery
that's playing behind you.
So you're seeing a half billion
pixels in every single frame
of that video.
And so visibility and
accuracy advantage
comes from the ability
to combine multiple input
sources into the models.
There's not really one
data set that provides you
all the answers to the really
consequential problems.
And so these are across
spatial, spectral, and temporal.
And it's this fusion
of both internal data
sets that we build as a company,
but it's also public data sets.
We have a lot of stuff--
imagery from, say, NASA
or European Space Agency,
institutions like that.
It's commercial data
sets, and they all
have a critical time and a place
context that's really required
to produce accurate models.
So right here, I would
like to just dive
deeper into what
I'm talking about.
As an example, this
is Des Moines, Iowa.
It's kind of a--
I don't know-- do we have
anyone from Des Moines?
I don't see anyone.
OK.
I didn't think so,
but you never know.
So this is a combination
of urban and agricultural
landscapes.
We're seeing the vector
data on the right.
This could be
GroundTruth locations,
or maybe it's one of
our customer's pieces
of infrastructure
that they've wanted
to tag for changes over time.
And then we have--
on the far left,
we can show vegetation
and vegetative health.
And in the middle, you can see
that synthetic aperture radar
I was talking about earlier.
The really bright pink and
white is higher-height objects.
And the challenge is making
a range of different sensor
outputs from a range of
different agencies like NASA
or European Space Agency.
Make it all uniform
and queryable,
so they can be used as all--
all as inputs for those models.
And so our customers and
our team of applied research
scientists solved a pretty
broad range of problems with ML.
And so every week, we bring
new sensors and new data
sets in to try and
solve those problems.
So what are some of
those examples of types
of models that we've built?
To extract the most data, we've
built this modeling platform
for complex global systems.
And now, we have
around 15 petabytes
of data in our archive.
And with this full historical
time stack, what it does
is allow us to go
back through time
and track both
conditions and outcomes,
so we can generalize
that relationship.
And then, we can use
it to make predictions
based on today's observations.
And then, we can
track new outcomes,
and we can measure accuracy.
And we can basically
continuously
be updating these models.
So this is an example.
This is showing construction
and buildings being started,
and that's correlated
to steel demand.
This is another example
showing object detection.
We are doing detection
on buildings,
and we have run this on the
entire state of California,
as well as numerous
other parts of the world.
And actually, one
of our scientists
was just telling me yesterday
that last Friday, we
were trying to understand
things like hurricanes
and maybe how hurricanes might
impact a state like Florida.
And in just a few hours,
they were able to scale up
and basically map out
every single building
in the state of Florida.
Another example is more
from the agriculture side,
and that is crop classification.
In the center image,
you see that--
all those really bright colors.
What we've done is
actually segment
out different
agricultural fields
to be able to identify
which crops are growing.
Is there wheat or soybeans
or barley or something else?
And then, we can use that
historical set of data
to go back and
train through time
and see how those models
performed in various seasons.
Some years, you
might have a drought.
Other years, we have tons
of rain and flooding.
So you need to be
able to compare
with known truths over time.
And to give you just an idea--
this is a tech conference.
And we talk a lot
about compute and scale
and things like that--
just to quantify what type
of scale some of these models
run at.
In 2015, we were just a
few-month-old company,
and we made our first
agricultural models.
And that was looking at
the entire United States
and our production of corn.
And so to build those
models, we processed
around 4 quadrillion
pixels of imagery,
so that's hundreds of
billions of iPhone photos.
And we wanted to
build a platform
that we really optimized
more for data scientist time.
We wanted to promote rapid
iterations of models.
To get the accuracy we were
looking for on that example,
it took nearly 1,000
iterations in just a few weeks.
So you can't get
that rapid cadence
of iterations on your
models without being
able to scale horizontally.
And so our team uses
our platform every day
to continuously
improve those products
and improve the scaling.
So hopefully, that
provides you an idea
with a breadth of the
types of ML models
that we wanted to
be able to run.
That was kind of the goal of
what we were trying to build.
What does our
workflow look like?
Well, we start with
the discovery phase.
We investigate a hypothesis.
We look at what types of
data sets we have available,
maybe what other data set we
could bring in to help fuse
together and provide insight.
And then, we build a
lot of candidate models
off those data sets.
We create and evaluate
those over historical
or maybe a known truth.
Maybe I knew where a
location of a building
was or a radio tower
or something like that.
And then, that model that starts
being evaluated and tested.
And finally, it goes
into production.
And then, as we get new sensor
data in all the time just
streaming, it's
continuously updated,
and it basically generates
a continuous time
series of analytics.
So you can use our tools
to make your own models,
or our team of data
scientists can actually
build them on your behalf.
And so at this
point, I'd like to do
a really quick demonstration.
And it's a demonstration
of typing my password.
What we did was we
took a big composite.
This is aerial imagery
of the entire US.
This is all actually stored.
We don't actually store
any of this on PD disks.
Oh, haven't switched yet.
SPEAKER 1: [INAUDIBLE].
OK, [INAUDIBLE].
Are you good?
TIM KELTON: Oh, here we go.
All right, try two.
So one interesting thing--
none of this data is
actually stored on PD disks.
This is all being
served straight off GCS.
So that kind of gives you an
idea of the speed of the Google
network and GCS storage.
But this is a huge map.
This is tens of
terabytes of imagery.
So if you had to zoom in
and look for objects inside
of that, say,
football fields, and I
needed to look across terabytes
and terabytes of imagery
and find every single
football field, that would
take a huge amount of time.
And so what we've done is we've
gridded that huge composite
image into tiny little grids,
and then we've built a feature
vector of each of those
tiny little 128-by-128-pixel
vectors.
And then, we have similarity
search-ranked them.
And so what you're seeing is the
most similar objects to the one
I just selected.
And so I could do
this for anything.
It could even be the railroad
tracks right next to it.
And it shows me all of them all
of the most similar objects all
across that entire composite.
So that's a really quick
example of the types of models
we're trying to build.
So at this point, just
talking a little bit more
about the GCP
infrastructure that we use--
we kind of have two main
portions of our infrastructure
that we've--
we have the ingestion.
And that's a very
large bulk processing.
And getting all of that
data machine learning ready
is kind of how we phrase it.
And then there's our
core APIs, and those
are more microservices-based.
And that's where we run all
of our user workloads as well.
So let's dive in to a
little bit what we do.
To get that imagery
ready, that's
actually one of the
biggest computational jobs
we run as a company.
We have to convert and
georegister all of our imagery
for accurate alignment.
We have to convert it
to standard projections.
We need to do things like
remove clouds and cloud shadows.
These are really
pesky problems that
are kind of hard to deal with.
We have to adjust for the camera
angle of the sensor, the sun's
angle-- how that might affect
what we're seeing back.
We have to calibrate the
sensors against themselves
and their neighbors, and
compensate for degradations
at the top of the atmosphere.
So our goal is to take 20 years
of camera technology, which
things have changed
a bit in 20 years,
and to make those sensor
outputs uniform and queryable
and searchable all on the fly.
This is a real example
of what that looks like.
On the left, you
see raw completely
uncalibrated,
uncorrected imagery.
Notice the calibration issues,
the cloud cover, all of that.
Then as you move right, you
can see the corrected versions.
We also store vector data.
An example of vector data would
be maybe outlines of counties.
It could be state outlines,
city outlines, things like that.
Another example
might be statistics.
In this example, it's
actually the Panama Canal,
if you didn't recognize that.
And one thing you
might have is some sort
of a statistical data set.
You might say how many ships
pass through this portion
of the image.
So this is, from an
architectural perspective,
what those large bulk processing
workloads look like on GCP.
We source that data
and bring that in.
And then, we use Pub/Sub
for breaking all of our work
up into distributed
asynchronous tasks.
And Pub/Sub, we've found,
has scaled tremendously.
We can really, really
hit it quite hard.
And these asynchronous
tasks actually
fit really nicely into
things like preemptible VMs,
because each piece of work
is very, very small in unit.
And those machines
can go away tomorrow,
and we'll just keep
spinning up new ones.
So we love the cost
savings that we
can get when we leverage that.
And one of the first
examples of how we actually
gained a lot of
confidence that we would
be able to do this type
of workload on the Cloud
was scaling up and processing
a petabyte of imagery.
And we were able to scale that
up to around a 30,000 CPU core
job and then run and process
a petabyte of imagery
in about 16 hours.
And that gave us
confidence not just
that we could get tons
of cores, because we know
we can do that almost anywhere.
The bigger and harder
problems actually
are with the object storage.
Would GCS be able
to scale with that?
Would the actual
network, as we kept
adding more and more nodes,
would that be able to scale?
And so we've actually
seen close to
high-performance supercomputing
speeds on the GCS networks.
And then, we have
these other data sets.
They could be metadata
or information
about those raw pixels or
what we refer to as rasters.
That could be
informations about what
bands of light, what modalities,
what periods in time, things
like that.
We use all types of different
persistent databases
to store that.
And then for error
logging, tracing,
things like that, we're not
really in that business.
So we're happy to try
and use a no-op solution.
So there, we used things
like Stackdriver's tracing
error and monitoring.
So in terms of
our core APIs, how
do those microservices look?
We have around approximately
50 microservices.
Any given day, we have a new
pre-alpha or alpha service
coming up.
We have canaries
that we're trying out
and things like that.
So it's always in flux.
But one of the core things, the
reason we have microservices
and we adapt them, is we have
so many different data types.
It's actually really
handy to be able to pair
the persistent
backend storage with--
for each microservice
uniquely and then
be able to scale
them individually.
And Kubernetes
multi-tenancy policies
are generally set, most of the
time, on a namespace basis.
And we isolate various
microservices by namespace,
so then, we can explicitly
define policies.
We can explicitly
define how exactly
we want to see it scale
and react to load.
We can do scaling interaction.
We can control the
interaction that
goes through the control plane.
So that actually goes
through our core APIs,
and those core APIs become kind
of the heartbeat of our system.
Like we really need to know
and get as much visibility
into that.
Our end users, those
workloads are also
broke out into their
own namespaces.
Those workloads don't
have any interaction
with the backend
Kubernetes control plane.
For the most part,
that's all going
through our centralized
API, and that's
because on any given user, they
might be able to scale jobs
to 10,000 cores.
And that's not that
uncommon for us,
so we need to really funnel that
information almost as a proxy.
So here's how at least I have
thought about multi-tenancy
on Kubernetes.
This is an extremely
broad subject.
We could have a three-day
conference on it.
And there's an amazing
Kubernetes SIG working group
that I'd highly recommend if you
really want to dive super deep.
They have calls every week.
But for this, let's
define multi-tenancy
as a way to provide
isolation for each tenant.
That could be a user
or an application.
And on one extreme--
that would be the far left--
all of the users are
actually in an enterprise.
I know we don't trust
all our coworkers,
but let's say
semi-trusted, I guess.
And that's because
maybe that organization
has some sort of visibility
into the process and standards
and knowledge of the software
that's going on those notes.
You're not just letting a
regular user from the internet
throw code up and start running
in one of your namespaces.
And often, this paradigm
can parallel a lot
with what we see in kind
of traditional IT, right?
Where Kubernetes, you can
have almost a namespace admin,
that almost can kind of be
the centralized IT function
or how you're gatewaying
in or out of workloads.
And the far other
extreme would almost--
would be more of a
platform as a service
or a Kubernetes as a service.
You have completely untrusted
users running untrusted code,
and they're having direct access
straight into the Kubernetes
API and control plane.
You might need to do things
like sandbox those workloads.
You might need to isolate
them on physical VMs
or isolate them by
various node pools.
You could even need
to look at something
like G Advisor or
Kata Containers
to get that level of isolation.
Our platform is more of
a software as a service,
so it's really kind
of an in between.
The user interfaces
directly with our core APIs.
We don't actually
give direct access
to any of our Kubernetes
control planes.
And so those core APIs become
that funnel or that proxy
where all the traffic and the
interaction with the clusters
is coming.
And so we need to allow a
range of models to be executed.
Those are all Python code
on our API currently.
And so we want to isolate
each of those workers
by their own namespace, so
we can execute them and then
have them only
interact with our APIs.
So where does Istio come in?
As those core APIs become
that central proxy,
we need to get as much
visibility into that.
That affects how the
cluster's scaling.
That affects how
much money we spend--
things like that, that
we really care about.
So visibility becomes
absolutely critical.
And with distributed
microservices,
one of the biggest challenges
is around the network.
You've broken applications
out, and they can run
in many different locations.
So getting visibility into where
different services are running
in that inter-service
communication
is absolutely important
to get metrics in control.
And I would imagine
probably a lot of people--
and there's references in
some of the talks already--
are familiar with Istio.
It's an open source platform.
Google and a number of
others have contributed.
It gives us load-balancing
for HTTP and GRPC traffic.
You get fine-grained
control of traffic
and routing, retries,
things like failover,
fault injection, pluggable
policies, automatic metrics,
logs, traces, things like that.
In a way, it kind of
sounds a bit like magic.
But in a practical way, it's
actually quite a bit simpler.
This is a diagram of the
actual components there.
And really, one of the keys
of Istio is the Envoy Proxy.
Instead of adding
client libraries
and adding a client library
for every single service,
if I have a node app, I need
instrumentation libraries.
If I have Python, I need that.
If you even have something--
like we have Rust--
maybe you need instrumentation
libraries for all of those.
That Envoy Proxy,
instead, gets deployed
into your existing code.
This could be a Python server.
It could be a Tomcat server.
It could be anything like that.
And so all the traffic now
goes through that proxy.
And the proxy
automatically talks back
to the pilot component,
and the pilot
tells it where every
single service is,
where load-balancing is, if
there's any routing rules that
are in effect.
And then the mixer is
where all of the telemetry
and information
starts to come in.
There's a pluggable log
layer where all your logs
can get sucked up.
It could go into
something like Prometheus.
In our case, we'll use
things more like Stackdriver.
And then finally,
you have things
like MTLS for
service-to-service encryption.
So if you're building
a SaaS platform,
there's some additional
benefits to consider.
Maybe you might be thinking
about ingress or egress.
You might say, I'll
allow everything
at star.googleapis.com to
flow out into the world,
but I'm not going to actually
allow other sets of traffic.
You can put that
type of rule there.
Maybe you're getting a lot
of 500s, and for every 500,
you think it might
be a network blip.
You might want to do automatic--
I might want to retry it
three times before I actually
give it-- return back a 500.
Maybe you'd like to
do rate limiting.
Your auth server might be
hit five times a second.
That might be great.
But if it gets hit 50,000
times a second from one pod,
well, I usually would
call that a DDoS.
So that type of thing is what
we try and get out of Istio.
So here's a diagram of what
things look like afterwards.
And overall, it's actually
not that different.
That's actually really awesome.
You're not rewriting
that code just
to get that network
reliability and that visibility
between each of your services.
We're now injecting the
side car in with each
of those workloads.
Envoy reports all traffic
telemetry straight up
into the Istio mixer
and provides visibility
into each service--
who's calling the service, the
service-to-service automations.
Overall, we gain amazing
insights into our core APIs
that we actually
did not have before.
So with that, we
would like to do
a quick demonstration of some
of the multi-tenancy workloads.
And we will do a quick switch.
SAM SKILLMAN: Cool.
OK, so I'm Sam Skillman.
I head up the engineering
team at Descartes Labs.
So as Tim was
mentioning, we've got
a lot of different
workloads going on,
from the simple to
the very complex.
So I'm going to show a
bit of that right now.
So if I go to this little
simple application here,
this is going to use
our asynchronous task
runner to essentially
say, hello, world.
What we do here is we
define some function.
It's going to end
up posting a message
to some webhook on Slack, which,
if the internet keeps working,
I'll start to see
notifications on my desktop.
I go ahead and create that
function, give it a name,
give it some Docker
image that runs,
how much memory
it's going to need.
This is kind of similar to
like a Cloud Function-like
functionality,
serverless application.
And I'm just going to run this.
And I do that.
And I can monitor what's going
on through this interface here.
So we see that there's
10 pending messages here.
So as that goes out
within Kubernetes,
this is now finding
appropriate resources
to place those workloads,
spin up those containers.
And you can see
that we're starting
to get Slack messages
saying, hello one, hello two.
So that's all seeming to work.
We can attach a webhook
to that task, where
I post a message saying
like, what's next?
And eventually,
this would come in.
We see that there's one
pending message there.
While that's running,
we can look in here,
look at logs for what
happened to those messages.
We do something like this.
And that was the log
from one of those--
that Python function.
This is just showing you the
very basic functionalities
there.
Let's see-- I think the hello
next has not quite come in yet.
But we don't make any money
off of saying, hello, world.
We spend most of our time
running very large machine
learning workloads at scale.
To give you an idea of
this, I had an idea--
I guess it was probably
like a few days ago--
where you see some
really cool stuff,
like taking a Keras model that
takes the style of one image
and applies it to a
set of other images.
So I was like, OK, that would
be pretty cool if we could
pull this off during the demo.
So we'll see if we can do it.
So I essentially just copy and
pasted this whole workflow here
from Keras and modified it a bit
so that what's going to happen
is--
let's see-- I'm going to take
Sentinel-2 imagery, which is
from the European Space Agency.
It revisits the same place on
Earth every five days or so.
I create a composite
from that and then
run this large neural
net transfer of one
style to another.
The details would take, again,
much longer than we have left.
So what I've done is I've
already actually started
running some of those while I
was sitting in the chair right
here.
But what you can see
happening on the backend
is that this has taken a--
taken our kind of
internal namespace
for each individual
user and started
scaling up the workload here.
So if I get a new fresh look
on here, this is climbing up.
This is 200 cores at the moment.
So this started at 107
about six minutes ago.
And as the system responds
to increased load, to more
tasks running,
needing to be run,
it continues to scale that
up in a way that doesn't just
send a DDoS attack to
our internal services.
So it kind of gradually
increases load over time.
We'll come back to
this in a second.
Let's see.
So a lot of these
ones were quick ones,
but then what this
has done is then
taken that Sentinel-2
imagery, downloaded it,
extracted the style,
actually, from "Starry Night."
It's like kind of
the canonical version
to take style from and
apply it to elsewhere.
It's then created a new
data set in our system
as part of our platform.
Sits right next to the
rest of our satellite
imagery, other
remotely sensed data,
and started
registering data to it.
So this is the
Sentinel-2 transfer live.
It looks like we've gotten
six scenes acquired so far.
If I try to open this up,
let's see if we can find it.
It might take a little while.
So the good thing is I've
got some backup here.
If you let this run for
about another 10 minutes,
you'll start to see the effect.
So if we zoom out here,
this is United States.
This is kind of
California over here.
It looks quite neat
over in Africa.
And so if we zoom
in here, we can
start to see the kind
of swirly patterns
that you get out of a
"Starry Night" painting.
And so this took something
like 2,000 or 3,000 cores.
It'll eventually scale up
to maybe 20 minutes or so.
And that's all running within
my Kubernetes namespace that
is dedicated just to
my user so that this
doesn't impact other users
running on the system.
We use all the
autoscaling abilities
within Google Container
Engine to just handle whatever
increased load we have.
Alongside of that, these are
hitting our internal APIs
at an increasingly high
load when it's calling out
to get those rasters
of Sentinel-2 imagery,
so those are also,
in turn, scaling up
as the load scales up itself.
Last night, which
was quite fun, I
took a different data set, which
was the National Agriculture
Imagery Program does a
high-resolution collection
over the United States
roughly every year.
We might have to
get a-- there we go.
So this is kind of the input
data that went into this one.
And if I look at what
happens to that--
we can zoom in
here on AT&T Park.
But this also took
about 10 minutes or so
but scaling up to
1,000 or 2,000 vCPUs.
Let's see how our
workload is going here.
We're starting to
scale up, only 250.
But that's not too bad.
Yeah, so it's
starting to process.
Let's see if we can
get lucky and find
one that's just been live.
There we go.
So this was processed.
We can take a look at it and
say, take a look at this.
And you can see that it was
acquired-- this is all UTC
time-- so 1:17 Pacific.
So that's one of the examples
of meshing a whole lot of things
together.
Our internal data catalog
is, as Tim mentioned,
over 10 petabytes
of input data, all
being able to run custom
machine learning models--
in this case, using TensorFlow
combined with Keras--
to do a fairly kind of useless
from a business perspective,
but interesting from
a compute perspective,
application all within the
same system but namespaced out
and being able to track that
using all the kind of metrics
that you can collect through
Istio and all the other tools.
So I think that's
about it for that.
You can see here--
actually, I can scale
this up real quick so
that you can see
that this is just
processing like 3,600 messages.
There's a bunch that
don't have any imagery,
like over the ocean.
This is currently up to
47 concurrent workers.
Each of those workers
have, I think, 16 cores.
And so that's starting to
be a real computation there.
So that's it for that.
Should I just
transfer over to the--
TIM KELTON: Oh, yeah.
Looks like we already
have our last side.
So with that, that's most
of what we had to show.
But some of you might be
saying, hey, I have a use case.
I don't want to download
petabytes and petabytes
of data.
I know how to build ML models.
Well for that, we actually
have a platform that we offer,
and you can get started
right away if you
have visibility into Python.
So we have docs there and
how to contact us and stuff.
The earlier example
I showed, Search,
is available at
search@descarteslabs.
You could look for other things
besides railroads and baseball
fields or football fields.
And then finally,
if any of you are
interested in working
on this type of stuff,
we're always looking for
more brilliant people.
So with that, I'd
like to thank you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]